JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome to recitation.
In lecture you've learned
how to compute derivatives
of polynomials,
and you've learned
the relationship between
derivatives and tangents lines.
So let's do a quick example that
puts those two ideas together.
So here I have a
question on the board:
compute the tangent
line to the curve y
equals x cubed minus
x at the point (2, 6).
So why don't you
take a minute, work
on that yourself, pause
the video, we'll come back
and we'll do it together.
All right.
Welcome back.
So we have this function,
y equals x cubed minus x.
Let's just draw a
quick sketch of it.
So looks to me like it has
zeros at 0, 1, minus 1.
And it sort of does something
like this in between.
Very rough sketch there.
And way over-- well, OK.
We'll call that
the point (2, 6).
Feel a little sketchy,
but all right.
OK.
So we want to know
what the tangent line
to the curve at that point is.
So in order to do that, we need
to know what its derivative is,
and then that'll
give us the slope.
And then with the
slope, we have the slope
and we have a point,
so we can slap
that into, say, your
point-slope formula for a line.
So, all right, so the derivative
of this function is y prime.
So, OK, so here we have
a sum of two things,
and they're both powers of x.
And so we learned
our rules for a power
of x that the
derivative of x to the n
is n times x to the n minus 1.
And so we also learned
that the derivative
of a sum of two things is
the sum of the derivatives.
So in this case, so the
derivative of x cubed
minus x is 3 x squared minus 1.
OK.
So this is the slope of
the function in terms of x.
But in order to compute
the tangent line,
we need the slope at the
particular point in question.
Right?
This is really important.
So we aren't going to use 3 x
squared plus 1 as our slope.
Right?
We want the slope at
the point x equals 2.
Right?
OK.
So what we want for the
slope of the tangent line
is y prime of 2.
Right?
We want it at this point
when x is equal to 2.
So that's equal to, well, 3
times 2 squared is 12, minus 1
is 11.
So this is the slope, this is
the slope of the tangent line.
I just want to say this
one more time for emphasis.
This is a really
common mistake that we
see on lots of homework and
exams when teaching calculus.
You have to remember
that when you compute
the slope of the tangent line,
you compute the derivative
and then you need to
plug in the value of x
at the point in question.
Or the value of x and y.
You know, you need to plug
in the values of the point
that you have.
So here, the derivative
is 3 x squared minus 1,
so the slope at the
point (2, 6) is 11.
It's just a number.
The slope at that point
is that particular number.
OK, so now, to compute
the tangent line,
we have a point, (2, 6),
and we have a slope, 11.
So we can plug into
point-slope form.
So the equation of the-- on
the-- tangent line is y minus 6
is equal to 11 times x minus 2.
Right?
So it's y minus y_0 is equal
to the slope times x minus x_0.
If you like, some
people prefer to write
their equations of their
lines in slope-intercept form.
So if you wanted to do
that, you could just
multiply through by 11 and then
bring the constants together.
So we could say, or
y equals 11x-- well,
we get minus 22
plus 6 is minus 16.
So either of those is
a perfectly good answer
to the question.
So that's that.